sortez ronald tv pour la suite de ce
championnat du monde féminin 2015
championnat du monde qui voit donc
s'opposer en finale maria am ozzy tchouk
face à la russe natalya pogo nina les
deux joueuses sont donc à égalité après
la première partie nul dans cette
seconde partie
l'ukrainienne musi chukka donc les
blancs il ya c'est parti tout de suite
sans attendre avec eux quatre
voilà donc où du pion du roi centrale eu
cinq cavaliers trois cavaliers ces six
fours et c'est normal habituels ont déjà
vu des parties dans ce championnat du
monde sur cette variante ça s'appelle la
variante espagnole où la rui lopes le
fou vient enlever cinq attaques
lecavalier 6 et on a vu des parties où
les noirs répondait ici par cavalier 6
la fameuse défense de berlin qui n'était
pas la plus usitée la plus connue avant
le championnat du monde kramis kasparov
de l'an 2000 c'est kramnik à populariser
cette vieille variantes qui revenue à la
mode mais ici on va voir à 6 voilà à 6
de la part des noirs donc là c'est la
fameuse la grande variante louis lopez
de l'espagnol grandes varennes de
l'espagnol on joue à six
on attaque le fou on n'a pas peur de fou
prend cavaliers puisque en général les
blés noirs prennent du plomb des et si
les blancs prennent le pion au sein qui
n'est plus défendu et on joue la dame
noire en d4 attaquant à la fois le
cavalier le pion aux 4 et donc les noirs
vont récupérer le matériel donc à 6 le
fou bien à quatre cas les pcistes
maintenant attaque le pion aux quatre
petit rock b5
pourchasse le fou fou b3 fawcett et tout
revient enfin ici protéger le pion 4 les
noirs n'ont pas perdu de temps pour
prendre le pion aux quatre ils auraient
pu essayer mais c'est d'autres variantes
ici ils laissent faire et simplement
pour préparer plus vite le petit rock et
ne pas perdre de temps alors à noter que
donc que les blancs ont laissé un petit
peu les noirs gagner du temps avec un
six dessins pour contrôler fou mais
l'idée ça peut être aussi que cette
structure elle n'est pas forcément
avantageuses pour les noirs elle peut
être faible puisque on peut maintenant
l'attaqué par à 4 donc c'est toujours
ambigu ces histoires de gagner de
l'espace on gagne de l'espace mais aussi
on donne des cibles d'attac à
l'adversaire donc c'est jamais à sens
unique des six alors attention des six
pour faire attention le fou mais dans
ces huit se libère donc il pourrait
venir angers 4 clouant le cavalier 3
c'est pour ça que la menace des quatre
l'immédiate ici jouer des cas tout de
suite se heurterait pourrait se heurter
à bouger 4 avec des problèmes pour les
pour les blancs qui qui peuvent
difficilement tenir le centre donc on
joue d'abord voit la c3 et en cas de fou
g4 ici les blancs ne jouerait pas des
quatre probablement mais plutôt des
trois ont bien protégé avec l'autre
cavaliers et ensuite on chassera le fou
avant de pousser des quatre plus tard
donc les noirs simplement rock ici et
voilà h3 donc h3c dans le but d'empêcher
la mana fou g4 qui quand même visa aux
contrôles noir sur des quatre qui déjà
bien défendus par le pion et par le
cavalier h trois ans n'empêche cette
manoeuvre de fou donc pour jouer des
cartes tout de suite sans passer par des
trois cavaliers des deux cavaliers mais
huit ans très surprenant c'est ce coup
le cavalier mais ça fait partie d'une
variante de l'espagnol y en a beaucoup
on peut aussi jouer cavalia cinq
attaques le fou le fou dans ce cas là
vient en c2 le plus souvent les noirs
poursuivre par ces 5
on vient en b vite parce qu'on veut
mettre le clavier non pas cinq où il
serait que excentré mais en 17
voilà c'est une variante des 4 et voilà
qu'à mener 17
le club olivier en dix-sept il protège
m6 et e5 maintenant que les blancs ont
joué h3 se fout sera bien placé en
bessette et on est un client 17 on est
peut-être enfin les noirs estiment
qu'ils sont peut-être mieux que s'il est
sur la bande
à 5 à 4 c'est ce que j'avais dit le fait
de laisser les noirs pousser ses pions
dans une cible menaces puis on prend b
scène puis on prend mes 5 et les tours
son emprise donc on a un problème avec
les noirs simplement fou 17 mois
maintenant surprise prises la tour à 8
et protégés à noter que le foot us ou 17
aussi attaque le centre 1
on continue par cavalli bd2 c5
tout est classique ici voilà c'est une
thématique ces structures de pions noirs
ici qui est extrêmement agressive un qui
est sûre la quatrième rangée noir qui
fait pression sur des quatre menaces et
entre guillemets des simplifications et
des 5 voilà on refuse de change des
pièces on est au 13e coup est noté qu'
aucune aucun échange n'a été fait ni de
pièces aucune pièce n'a été changé ni
deux ni de pions toutes les pièces sont
encore là donc la complexité de la
partie est à son maximum
ces quatre attaques le fou fou ces deux
gars va laisser 5
toujours aucun échange cavaliers f1
alors c'est souvent leader espagnol de
qualité devient f1 et ensuite il vient
se ranger 3 ou parfois même en h2 où il
vient au g3 si son compagnon qui vient
h2 et après on va sur la classe g 4 on
profite du fait qu'on a le pion h3 avec
une belle occasion j'ai 4 2 une sorte
d'avant poste pour aller créer un
cavalier qui protège qui attaquent des
cases proche du roi et en caprices des
noirs on reprend dû plonger avec un pion
qu'un pion jicky peu pénible qui va
jouer angers 5 et parfois il ya des
plans alors c'est des plans à long terme
mais on met le ranger de après g 3g 3
roger ii et la tour 1 e 1 va venir h1 et
on va attaquer le roi donc faut faire
c'est lent mais la position est ferme et
un donc voilà après des 6 e 5 et des 5 4
quand le centre est verrouillé on a
moins de danger attentes et les attaques
sur lèze voilà c'est un principe général
qu'il faut savoir donc inversement si
votre adversaire vous attaque sur l'ale
et que le centre n'est pas fermée mais
bien contre attaquer au centre que vous
allez voir que il aura des problèmes
tours 8 au retour 8
l'idée c'est moins mal et protéger une
scène qui est très bien défendus par des
six que de libérer une case et fluide
pour par exemple il met le fou est
préparé à moyen long terme une
protection du roi maximale voilà qu'avec
les g3 voilà ce qu'à lille j'ai trop con
la viny elissa casef scène déjà dont
kasparov disait si j'ai une pièce en f 5
ou notamment un cavalier si j'ai un
cavalier en 9,5 ça ça vaut un pion bon
c'est indiscutable comme affirmation
mais c'est vrai que c'est une case qui
est quand même extrêmement agressive
mais on n'atteint que sept g7 h6
pourquoi pas des six cavaliers qui
rayonne très fort maintenant que le fou
justement ne contrôle plus cette case f5
et maintenant que cavalli tanger 3 on
pourra aussi envisager le métrage 5
une fois qu'on aura joué cavalier f3 par
exemple en h2 justement on peut jouer
qu'avec la chaîne pour éliminer le un
défenseur du roi on note une petite
attaque contre le roi à noter que dans
cette structure on peut aussi jouer
facilement tour trois tours g3 avec une
tour carrée menthe qui vient attaque
donc alors que vous voyez que
l'adversaire ne peut pas venir 1,6 du
fait que le pion de d5 est quand même
plus avancé que le pion aux cinq des
noirs g6 allongée si ce contrôle
justement ces deux cases convient de
signaler et comme on a prévu justement
de jouer fouet fuite fou g7
on a affaibli modérément les cases
noires puisqu il nous reste le fou donc
papa de façon extrêmement graves fautes
3 on pourquoi pas
dames c'est cette cavale et des deux
alors ça c'est un autre plan que celui
qu'on a dit que les d2 a donc il fallait
faire attention
enfin il faut faire attention aux plus
hauts cadres dont il est très bien
défendu un déjà a maintenant trois fois
il a attaqué deux fois deux fois ça
suffisait donc à idées de jeu sur des
formes peut-être que j'ai envie de venir
en f1 enfin ne joue pas je sais pas ce
que je veux faire avec ce qu'avait en
fait voilà moi je n'aime pas trop ce
coup là mais même fou 3 j'aime pas trop
je pense que moi je rajoute l'alliage
qu'il faille et 4 mais bon pourquoi pas
on est au 18e coup aucune aucun échange
pas depuis en échange elle pas de pièces
extraordinaires cette partie faut il
suit mais c'est typique de l'espagnol
dames 2 non mais la case sur la dame
pardon sur une bonne case en vaut deux
parce qu'on protège des trois qui peut
un peu faible quand même un pion qui
protège alors qu'il ya pas de pions
blancs il faudra donner le fou ici on
travaille bien et puis surtout on lit
les tours voilà au point de
finissons développement tranquillement
cavaliers f17 1
pourquoi pas on écoute cavaliers
maintenant quatre prises en c5 je peux
remplacer par un autre cavalier f3 f3
tranquille surprotège le pion aux quatre
alors c'est peut-être l'idée de calais
des deux joue câbles et des deux pour
jouer trois mélanges et plus jamais de
problème sur quatre bon maintenant aussi
pour attaquer sur les colonnes comme on
l'a vu avec un pourrissement c'est pas
possible
mais c'est très sale air très très
solide au temple à 15h05 ici qui serait
une case d'attac pour les noirs avec le
coeff scène est loin d'être possible
puisqu'il ya le pion qui protège une
première fois qu' on a le cavaly g3 et
le fou ces deux cette case f5 et
verrouillé donc les blancs ont les mains
libres pour faire des plans long terme
peut-être cavaliers fin cave alliage
deux cavaliers g4 a taclé petit peu les
casses faible et puis si on pousse les
noirs jouent fch 5 on est content on
affaiblit les noirs lors s'affaiblissent
tout seul câble et b6 alors attention
maintenant il ya une pression sur à
quatre baies 5
est-ce que c'est leur peu de faire le
premier échange avec apprendre b5
attention suspense et non à cinq
donc à cette attaque la cavaille v6 et
web alors si on vient b4 on risque de ne
plus jamais pouvoir partir de là car il
y a quatre je ne sais pas si on peut pas
jouer tour à 2 simplement pour défendre
b2 et le câble et à 4 sortira plus
jamais il sera un défi nitivement isolé
en a quatre donc on revient 17 cavaliers
fh1 regarder on n'a pas peur de faire
des longues manoeuvre parce que tout est
verrouillé toujours aucun échange
fawcett g4 ça y est le centre est bloqué
l'ale dame est bloqué on peut envisager
en étant prudent bien sûr mais on peut
envisager bien sûr d'envoyer les pions
de l'aileron assure le roi adverse
parce que les pièces blanches sont mieux
situer que les pièces noires en attaque
et que les pièces noires ont des
problèmes de défense puisqu'ils ne sont
sûrs que sur deux rangées le pion d66
disons bloquant un peu une défense sur
la troisième donc onu et surtout sur
deux rangées en a - espace donc ça peu
peur dtn l'attaquent d'amd 8 protège et
15 noir sur protéger les classes noir
d'un f2 provoque les noirs et vient me
chercher en h4
ok mais je viens je viens acheter à tout
l'intention bien sûr là mais tours mais
mais mais bien entendu calligé trois ont
marqué les renvoyer qu'on a joué car vih
1 pour jouer g4 et on revient en g3 pas
de problème le cavalier empêche le fou
d'avoir une action pour ces huit roi
j'ai deux m'ont plu roi qui protège le
cavalier tranquillement à noter
maintenant presque à tout moment on va
pouvoir mettre des tours et dames sur la
colonne f jouer f4 et une envie enfin
une possibilité on peut l'envisager
simplement en cas de prise des noirs on
peut ouvrir la colonne mais attention
puisque ça libère la case de 5 pour
lequel les dix-sept avec un bon cavalier
centrale vous faire attention cavaliers
fuite
touré fin peu menacé d'ouvrir ou g5
peut-être les noirs ici ont peur
justement de cette ouverture paraître 4
hélas comme un maître 4 voilà donc là on
sent qu'il va y avoir des échanges enfin
ont formé au 28e coup toujours aucun
échange est la première et charge de la
partie puis on prend un f4 ça a été très
long phu prend et tour c'est cette voie
là les noirs ont joué tour s'est vite
ours et 7 pour défendre la deuxième
travès regarder comment c'est très très
bien joué très malin maintenant
d'ailleurs le fou aussi qui bute pour
l'instant sur des cinq cas pourrait
envisager de venir assez vite pour
essayer de contrôler un peu les cases
blanches
voilà mais c'est une tour défensive très
bien placé il défense latérale classique
faut prendre d'un prend 1,7 et protégés
heureusement sinon une batterie d'un
tour qualif trois tacles adam dabo cette
position tendu toujours calé les d4 on
avance petit à petit sous cavaliers qui
était en d2 en f3 takada maintenant en
d4 commence à envisager des possibilités
sur des cases ennemi alors qu'ils sont
protégés bien sûr mais il faut pas non
plus oublier les poursuites et de
sacrifice par exemple cavaliers pour
venir en aide 5 se sacrifiant et
remplacé après puis on prend remplacé
par l'autre cavaliers et un cavalier
magnifique qui protège qui attaque
beaucoup de cases noires et il peut y
avoir des thèmes de maths il faut faire
attention faut être prudent avec les
noirs même si rien n'est clair la
position peut éclater à tout moment
c'est l'espagnol est une ouverture
extrêmement difficile à jouer qui peut
passer d'une position apparemment calme
à une explosion tactique il ya de
magnifiques parties
kasparov et karpov notamment dans les
années 80 dans une partie extrêmement
célèbres ou pas enfin sacrifice de dames
sur sur a6 je sais plus où soit sept
pour mater le roi noir de karpov dans
une partie magnifique dame cet aveu par
contre dame 5 pardon on verrouille les
case la case noire 5 on essaie
d'empêcher aussi le pion aux cadres
d'avancé attention à ce pion donc tard
envisage de se sacrifier et pourquoi pas
1 5 en libérant le fou attention bon pas
tout de suite mais il faut imaginer les
combinaisons tactiques qui pourrait y
avoir et lâche 4 blanc continue en
essayant de jouer
pourquoi pas h 5 voire pourquoi pas mg5
sans doute c'est encore mieux et si on
arrive ensuite à mettre un cavalier
imaginer sur la case g4 et bien ça y est
on a un pion que j'ai 5 ans + qui
protège les casses faible m6 et h6 le
foot case noire disparu et on sent bien
que ça va être difficile h6 voilà on
remet un pion sur place noir on commence
à contrôler un peu cette case gsm
comprend qu'il peut se passer des choses
voilà c'est le problème comme des deux
attaques la faiblesse fou s'est vite
alors ça c'est tactique les noirs
répondent par un coup de contre attaque
d'école et noir ne peuvent n'ont rien pu
faire depuis depuis longtemps ils sont
obligés ils ont été obligés un peu
d'attendre d'attendre d'attendre les
blancs patiemment ont construit vous
avez vu cette petite extension aller
loin tranquillement et puis là les noir
sans qu'il faut faire quelque chose
sinon ils vont finir étouffé cabale et
c6 et oui c'est le problème le fou bombe
si bien ils se vengent sur g4 contrat
chis mais la casse et si ce n'est plus
protégé donc le cavalier viennent ces
six attaques la dame dame g7
voilà très bien au bon moment le bla
damien qui est en attaque et viande g7
protège la case faible h 6 et le pion g4
reste en prise et voilà d'un f4
cette passe d'armes est logique tour 17
coups étonnant sur un ton 17
on s'attend pas à tour 17 mais
évidemment le problème c'est le pion des
six que faire d'autre
il n'y a pas d'autres coups en fait à
part le coup quand même assez les
cavaliers bessette mettre en cavale et
sur la case bessette c'est certainement
une des clauses les plus les plus
malheureuses pour un cavalier lac aspect
c'est tout ce type de position donc tour
17 défend le pion des six mais bush
la diagonale du coup voilà donc c'est
quand même une tour extrêmement passive
et en plus qui est éteint la possibilité
pour le fou ces huit de jouer la toile
de ce prêt spa avec les blancs web 2e
question faire des ronds pourquoi pas
triplé pourquoi pas triplé sur la
colonne f et au bon moment a lancé une
attaque décisive
regardez comme les noirs sont ficelés
issifou bessette et on regarde des 4
après avoir désorganisé quelque peu les
pièces noires on revient dès 4 ans gagne
du temps comme ça avec ces manoeuvres
tour ou cinq taureaux scène c'est quoi
l'idée bon je protège un peu cet
étranger bon d'accord mais surtout bien
je neutralisent l'action de la dame sur
le pion des six donc ça peut libérer la
tour 17
car les trois tacles à tours tours 8 et
g5 seller et oui parce que maintenant
que le carry trade 3g 5,6 des noirs
prennent prise prise c'est pas bon du
tout puisque la torah va venir sera
chaud avec la taxe sur la colonne h et
en plus le cas les trois ils rêvent que
de ça de venir en h2 pour sauter
regardez ce cavalier avec les flèches on
va le montrer hop et dc up est d'ici
le sauté alors hop sur la case et 6
manoeuvre de cavaliers qu'on a envie de
faire en jouant g5 on libère la case g4
donc h5 pour empêcher cette manière nous
vaut certainement pas les lignes contre
le roi le problème maintenant c'est
quand toujours pareil quand on avance
des pions les affaiblit ce pur hcm et
ainsi une cible est bien protégé par g6
mais ça peut faire l'objet justement de
sacrifices imaginons que l'autre
cavailles reviennent en d4
on pourrait envisager cavaliers prend h
5 puis on prend le cavalier ici
viendrait sur la cazelle cinq attaquants
la dame visant la casa chis avec échec
puis la classe f 7
ça serait un massacre et voilà
d'ailleurs qu'elle ait des cats donc là
une des menaces cavaliers prend avec
derrière cavaliers f5 et pourquoi pas
une invasion par cavalier h 6 échecs
suivi éventuellement de la prison fc
être pourquoi pas des manoeuvres aussi à
base de 1,5 sacrifice de pions libérant
la possibilité pour le fou c'est de
dégager cette diagonale
attention cependant c'est que quand on
joue à 5 le fou 17 se réveille bien sûr
attention sur des cinq sur le roi il
faut calculer ça mais c'est des
possibilités qui sont dans l'air du
temps
dames 5 voilà dames 5 et en cas de prise
en âge 5 et de caviar c'est on échange
les dames et si les dames sont plus là
l'attaqué pas c'est pas rien et sur
domptable d2 en échange pas les dames
tours détours ces sept on veut
maintenant regarder les noirs se disent
bon moi même j'ai affaibli quelque peu
les cases blanches des blancs enfin
quand ils se sont affaiblies aussi
puisqu'ils ont avancé leurs pions
ce puis enchaîne contrôle donc si
j'arrive à jouer fou s'est vite fou j'ai
4 ans g4g une pièce dans le camp ennemi
et puis je protège très très bien h5
voilà donc en jouant tour ces sept on
veut envisager tour c'est 8 pouces et 8
pardon et fuji 4 très certaine voilà
doublage l'ong bloom
attention tour cette voie la
surprotection surprotéger 7 et la tour
et 6 ça fait peur hein ça fait peur le
cette tour est quand même très très bien
placé les blancs en plus ici en faisant
sa coupe la retraite de la dame là d'un
peu plus venir à les défendre l'euro
angers7
et ça peut être un thème imaginons des
coups comme dans me2 cavale et prend
puis on prend dame prend et tout de
suite on voit bien que par exemple tout
racisme
non toi je ne marcherai pas mais
peut-être g6 avait des menaces de maths
quasiment imparable il faudrait calculer
ça en détail mais on va pas le faire
sans tarder toutes les rentes y en
aurait beaucoup trop mais c'est des
thèmes qui plus est on n'a peut-être pas
peur même de donner la qualité
réussissent parce que on pourrait
reprendre par exemple du pion ou
remplacée par une tour mais peut-être
prenante du pion en contrôlerait la
casse g7 avec des thèmes là aussi
sachant qu'à tout moment on peut jouer
qu'à lille iii qui chasse la dame noire
à noter que c'est la menace un ici c'est
de jouer cavalier des 4es ovale à la
main la dame est en prise
attention c'est aussi le thème donc la
voie la tour 17 et forcé pour libérer la
dame en cas de kf3 on peut s'échapper
doivent 4 on revient p4 les noirs
essayer de faire quelque chose
côté dames un niveau bien qu'ils sont
verrouillés s'ils font rien ils vont se
prendre tôt ou tard un cavalier prend
aux cinq cavaliers f5 avec une invasion
il n'y a pas besoin de savoir calculer
beaucoup pour voir que l'attaqué très
forte
typiquement bon là il faut faire
attention faut tout calculer on est un
parti longue la moindre erreur en
attaque serait fatal
et si typique des positions ou en blitz
on réfléchit pas on sacrifie quasiment
les yeux fermés ce qu'on sent que
l'attaqué très très forte
khalef trois tacles adam ii
j'essaie de me revient au g7 et on prend
des 4 alors qu'elle est l'idée des noirs
pourquoi ils ont laissé faire pourquoi
ils ont joué b4 et bien voilà ils
veulent jouer cavaliers detroit il
étonnant vu qu'on a pris avec le pion
c'est en cas de prise en d3 prise prise
d'un prend et bien la tour c 7 à un peu
de jeu sur la colonne s'est on va
essayer de contourner
finalement le bloc central très bien
tenu des blancs par la colonne c'est au
prix d'un pion pénétrer avec ses tours
et ses traits du con tre jeune attaquant
leroy laurent blanc de façon à ce que
les blancs ici on se défend la pression
sur le roi noir s'allège défense la
meilleure défense c'est l'attaqué
toujours donc tous rêvent 6 en relief 6
avec la tour qui était attaqué par le
cavalier et a donc on ne prend pas en
rentre pas dans le piége 9 km h cette
attaque la tour ni la tour n'a pas de
case salle et blanc en vue prévoit parce
que sinon c'est embêtant qu'avait en
gagnent la qualité mais non regardez
tout simplement en tout cas les d4 on
n'a pas peur de donner à qualité sur les
hits à l'heure c'est parce que même avec
une la qualité ça c'est pas le thème ici
le thème cycles au roi noir est sous
pression maximale t elle les prend et
puis on prend voilà on appris du pillon
la dame doit jouer donc par exemple en
fuite pourquoi pas bon est-ce qu'on peut
envisager d'un mach 6 ici c'est une
possibilité qui semble possible
ben on peut pas regarder tout simplement
d'un portable
idiot j'aurais mieux fait de me taire
donc après puis on prend dame f8 voilà
tout simplement
regardez donc la dame contrôle ici en
réussissant une voix le pion contrôle
des cases sensible recettes et surtout
j'essaie est roi le cavalier blanc des
quatre peut sauter ans et six en six ans
au f5 remplacé par son collègue le pion
h5 peut être pris à tout moment il peut
se passer des trucs et là soit 4 très
jolie magnifique donc on sait qu'on veut
pas prendre ici on vient chatouiller la
tour 17 berry elle va ou parce qu'on a
tout pris vous voyez c'est un pseudo
sacrifice de qualité que font les noirs
pour il aurait pu jouer tourner vite
mais il préfère jouer cavalier 5 et
venir avec le cavalier sur la case eu
cinq en défense essayer de protéger
voilà on protège ses cases en cas de
sacrifices on pourrait ramener un k way
en défense donc on reprend la qualité
tout d'abord pour 30 ou reprend et
maintenant on regarder ce que nous fait
maria musi tout tranquillement qualif 3
se presse pas on pose la question aux
cavaliers e5 on menace de le prendre
puis on prend et après on avait en plus
maintenant on a un pion passé centrale
et on a toujours une attaque donc avalé
g4 voilà c'était l'idée de cailloux 5
bien au g4 tranquillement et la
magnifique suite magnifique suite de my
name is it you qui calcule tout on est
quand même en finale de championnat du
monde
regardez superbe boum c'est leur bouffe
entendu bon moment marjanovic ou
qu'elles estiment que c'est leur
sacrifice de cavalli sur hcm voile avait
tout ému rien regarder les pièces
blanches se caille est prêt à sauter
pourquoi pas en déca pour venir au fc
est pourquoi pas en bien sûr un g5 ce
qui semble le plus le plus dangereux
la tour est fin et prête à rentrer un
jour pour jouer très vite dès que ce cas
il ya joué tout reste trois touchés
trois voire même on pourrait enlever le
roi par exemple en h1 tour g1
attaquerait le roi aussi et la dame est
prête à revenir sur la sur la diagonale
bon il faut calculer ça une précision
mais c'est faux si c'est faisable
là les noirs auraient dû accepter la
perte du pur h5 mais s'ils acceptent ça
par exemple tout s'est vite pour essayer
de revenir en défense des cases noires
des cases blanches pardon se ressource
sur cette grande diagonale mais
simplement dans ce cas là le par exemple
ici on imaginer ça tient un blog ici
simplement les blancs pourrait tout
simplement joué par exemple câbles et
des cas tout simplement continent à
atteindre les 100km emprise c'est
possible puisque sur puis on prend
d'avoir un peu la même variante que dans
la partie et la dame avec menace aussi
de venir en gsm on peut aussi envisager
plus tard de jouer cavalier g3 et h5 le
cavalier protégeant la cave et h5 avec
ce pur h4 qui peut en plus augmenter là
le coup de bélier un contrôle et noir
donc c'est parce que le font les noirs
les noirs ici après accepte le sacrifice
d'accord et là regardez simplement et
c'est sans doute le pal forcément le
meilleur coup mais ont reconnu que les
noirs sont quand on est sous pression on
est aussi au 54e coup donc le temps doit
commencer à manquer pour les noirs qui
ont défendu toute la partie vers des
méthodes la combinaison finale est
magnifique
donc on en a vu comment cette partie
s'est déroulée un objet cinq échecs
il n'y a pas trop le choix qu'est ce
qu'on fait
ensuite et simplement d'un proche cinq
échecs attaque le cavalier donc si les
noirs joues ta match si ce qui semble
moins normal simplement je reprends le
cavaly j'attaque la tour noter que
j'attaque la tour et bien j'ai gagné
deux pions gratuit puisque je récupère
la pièce sacrifié avec une très belle
position j'ai même pas besoin de
calculer plus pour voir que c'est
extrêmement bénéfique pour les pour les
blancs
donc là les noirs jouent caillage 6 pour
garder au moins la pièce de plus ce qui
semble tout à fait logique et la
regarder coup tranquille superbe proche
d'eux à noter que regarder qu'on met le
roi sur une case noire ce qui évite de
se prendre un échec plus tard de toute
façon pourquoi aurais-je 2 bah c'est pas
tellement l'idée de protégeront assez
qu'on veut mettre la tourangelle mètres
la tour à gérer on menace de venir en g7
la dame est coupé de la défense du
cavalier et seimat rapide donc les noirs
jouent des rucks dame g8 semble un des
rares coups possibles pour jouer la dame
en acheter mais regardez tout simplement
tour g1 quand même et les noirs
abandonnent magnifique victoire leur
faut quand même voir pourquoi les noirs
abandonnent ici alors à noter que ici
les blancs auraient pu avant de toucher
1 simplement prendre prendre le cavigal
6 si on prend le câblage 6 c'est
possible parce qu'à l'aller d'anjou dame
h7 est le meilleur ici pour les blancs
c'est sans doute tout simplement de
revenir en par exemple en f4 tout en en
gardant la tacc on veut jouer ensuite
tous que j'ai eu un tour g7 voir que
des cavaliers h cinq ou six sont
possibles on garde la tacc on est
beaucoup mieux on a quand même regarder
un deux trois quatre pions pour les
noirs 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 pour les blancs en
trois points de plus le roi qui est
complètement aux fraises bon est ce que
c'est la peine voyez donc c'est quand
même tout à fait magnifique après
qu'elle ait si djezzy
tous rejettent encore plus fort très
certainement attaque la dame est là il
n'y a pas trop le choix
si damas fuite on l'a vu tout rejet
cette coupe la dame et c'est fini objet
de donner la dame est le seul autre coup
semble être donc dame h7 qui défend
encore un tout petit peu et regardez
simplement jouer cavalier g5 magnifique
la dame est attaqué si elle vient au g8
cette fois je prends le cahier avec la
dame et ses mates d'un match 7 d'un
point est mat ça c'est facile à voir et
là que font les noirs le seul coup qui
semble logique ces dames g6 et on se dit
mais on s'en sort
oui c'est ce que c'est vrai ça a l'air
bon regarder puisque mg6 menace
d'échanger les dames et puis finalement
les menaces en l'air de s'évanouir un
peu et non regardez il ya un magnifique
coup ici encore cavalli bref cet échec
c'est horrible et latour attaque la dame
donc on n'a pas le choix
surtout reprend évidemment père la dame
tout simplement donc simplement on fait
dans prend 7 et la regarder ses ailes
très joli match d'impro h6 maintenant
mathé enfin pas tout à fait maths mais
vous allez voir la tour ici contrôler la
colonne j'ai donc le roi est en échec a
pas le choix il faut jouer avec 7 et ici
hop
de l'autre côté échec hélas cette fois
c'est mort puisque la tour protège donc
après dame g8 forcé simplement d'emprunt
j'évite échec et mat
magnifique victoire de marié amouzou
tubes dans une partie 1 qu'on l'a vu à
sens unique 1
typique de l'espagnol il ya fischer ces
fichiers qui disait bobby fischer qu'ils
y ont trait la vache et à la fin on
gagne on sait pas trop pourquoi parce
que impression c'est gagne à tous les
coups
c'est vrai que dans ce type d'espagnol
les blancs semblent pas avoir davantage
à part plus des spasmes et cet avantage
des espaces très souvent des coups sur
une attaque du roi mortels kasparov
aussi en a gagné plein et notamment
contre karpov des magnifiques plusieurs
dans les fameux match des années 80-90
face à kharkov en finale du championnat
du monde donc c'est défense espagnole
qui est difficile à jouer côté noir d'où
les coups sont quand même semble assez
assez évident qu'ils restent complexes
très longtemps et qui donne un avantage
long terme rampant un peu pour les
blancs avec parfois comme ça et bien des
maths imparable des montées en puissance
sur les le roi comme on l'a vu ici donc
peut-être pas un bon choix
mariam ou zouk semble excellemment jouer
cette partie espagnole avec donc les
blancs peut-être pas un bon choix pour
prouver ni d'avoir choisi cette cette
variable en tout cas après deux parties
donc maria musi tchouk mène 1 0 donc
dans ce championnat du monde il reste
deux parties mais elle peut l'emporter
dès la prochaine partie si elle gagne la
prochaine évidemment le mènera de deux
points alors qu'il restera plus qu'une
partie donc elle sera championne du
monde si elle gagne avec les noirs la
prochaine tandis que pour une hymne à
devoir revenir au score mais on l'a vu
on l'a vu on le répète ça fait quand
même trois matches de suite qu'elle nous
fait un retour puisqu'elle a elle est
revenue en huitièmes en quart et en
demie trois fois de suite pourquoi pas
en finale aussi la russe donc tout est
possible encore ça nous promet une fin
de match super intéressante dans cette
finale donc du championnat du monde 2015
à bientôt donc pour la suite sur
diagonale tv au revoir